-Your early acting life
was not even on camera.
You worked at a Ren Faire --
at a Renaissance Faire?
-I did, yeah.
-Wow.
-I worked a lot.
Grandma instilled it in me,
so, yeah.
So I had several --
-Did it, like, appeal to you
as an actor, or did it just
appeal to you as a job?
-As a job. It did.
-Yeah.
-I was always a little --
I loved it.
And I always hate
to be critical of people,
but I was a little creeped out,
because I was like 16
and looked like I was 14,
and I was
the cheese-bread wench.
[ Laughter ]
And there were 45-year-old
and older men
coming up and asking
the tarty wench
to "fetch them
ye meat pies and cheese bread."
And I was like -- So I'd
have to act like "ye wench."
[ Laughter ]
-How does a wench
even fetch bread
different than another person?
-I'm not sure.
And I really didn't know at 14.
-Yeah. Right.
-I could probably swing it now.
I could
fetch your cheese bread now.
-You could put a little wench
on it now, but back then...
-Now I could --
I could fetch your --
Oh, I was about
to say something so wrong.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna say it!
But it had to do
with the meat pie.
Let's just leave it...
-Gotcha. Let's just let --
And then let your minds
take you to wherever --
wherever it was
that you thought, Amy...
-Do like I stopped myself,
though.
-Yeah.
I like that you stopped yourself
and then you gave them
all the information.
[ Laughter ]
You actually made it somehow a
little bit worse than if you --
-A little worse.
-Yeah.
-That's kind of what I do.
I always make things
a little worse for myself.
-Yeah. But, you know,
I will say that I think
that some of those, you know,
45-year-old guys
who remember you
as the cheese wench,
they're home right now,
they're so much older,
and they saw that joke
you were gonna make,
and it made them happy.
-I'm glad.
[ Laughter ]
I'm glad.
If a joke about meat pie
can bring some Christmas joy...
[ Laughter ]
-They're like,
"Oh, our wench is all grown up!"
[ Laughter ]